a lot going on with the Royals and we
already know that Megan and Harry are
taking legal action against the British
press but today we learned exactly what
has megan fighting math a leaked
personal letter accusations of
overspending throwing down almost four
million dollars to renovate her new home
with Archie and Megan's mom snubbed
these are the reports that have the
Duchess suing the British tabloids not
many people have asked if I'm okay
in legal papers Megan tells her site
about the claim that she goes to her dad
after he bailed on her wedding the 38
year old says that's false as for the
letter he gave to the press Megan's mad
that only which she calls the bad parts
were published and why wasn't Megan's
mom Toria at the baby shower attended by
Amal Clooney and Gayle King the ditches
refutes that nine-month-old rumor saying
she offered to pay for dorias airfare
but her mom couldn't go to gym quotes
work commitments as for the defendant in
Megan's lawsuits The Mail on Sunday
tells et they will defend the case with
quotes the utmost vigor with all that
drama how to Harry and Megan get away
from it all
Netflix and chill it's been reported
they're big fans of the crown wonder
what he thinks of the actors playing his
father Prince Charles and his aunt
Prince Sam I gotta say Josh liked the
resemblance of yourself at a young
Prince Charles you're like what did you
get that growing up although I had a
very strange thing I guess the ears were
the thing that people talked about most
I am NOT just a symbol people are like
oh my gosh this is a hot Prince Charles
that's a nice thing my mom keeps away I
was a good-looking guy when he's young
alright thanks mom the crown has lots of
celebrity fans so excited the crown I
can't wait I'm ready
Olivia Wilde was honored with a
trailblazer award at the Napa Valley
Film Festival the book-smart director
says she'd love to cast the Queen Olivia
Colman and Helena Bonham Carter in a
possible book smart movie sequel in my
Wow there are no two women that I need
to
in Fillmore
[Music]